the from the white one a longer cable
I mean cupola someone got a look darling
to be dating
have you me global got my item warning
yah yah yah I'm got you we may go get
longing company or go enjoy
further the immunity daddy given dog is
on her that bb-8 it's not unusual to
find that the main electricity has been
tampered with
she's highly dangerous you know you're
risking your life and then you stay in
conditions they are breathing in sort of
the pollen from the cannabis plants
windows are taped up everything that's
running is usually on an extractor fan
with UV lights everywhere to grow the
crop they are horrendous conditions
if we're looking at Vietnamese nationals
there was a very typical trafficking
route and that's from Vietnam Russia
Germany France they will fly for the
first leg usually and then a lot of that
that journey through Germany and France
and Russia is done on foot in the
forests and they will be sleeping in
makeshift camps once they get to the UK
and they will usually be put in the back
of a vehicle that is transporting goods
and they will be made to hide in that
vehicle we're going to museum you let it
all by nothing ah time by number
theatres you do die look at Mililani ha
the fear for a victim of this kind of
exploitation cannabis farming I think is
quite extreme they're very frightened
and disorientated they don't speak
English if they did escape what would
they say who would they go to and so the
chances of them getting out of that
situation are often minimal
you know yet why chang-ho being a hole
to live or a video call but you know
totally totally vita k caitelady Mookie
someone with a diesel with a little mood
attack that cooked I will put idea that
one or number two you cheat me you can
get an accountability
let me check Monta amber do it all diver
so
Mooka can wear it you're elected and
here would be lamb you like the LOI put
it on the dangling it already qua hope
you take some questions
you